18h08 on est en direct sur brut rémy 21e
aujourd'hui françois ruffin on est donc
au sein de la rédaction route françois
ruffin sa première interview à un média
national depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois mais interné depuis l'année 2019
bonjour de françois ruffin bons joueurs
on va pas être pas mal de choses mais
surtout de votre livre que j'ai
peut-être vous laisser montrer l'image
voilà ça fait un peu de promo plus au
centre comme ça voilà ce pays que tu ne
connais pas bienvenus en france monsieur
macron alors j'aimerais d'avoir proposé
cette question justement parce que ce
titre est ce que ça veut dire quelque
part que c'est un président qui est
déconnecté du peuple pour vous et
pourquoi je pense qu'il n'a jamais été
le point de départ du livre c'est
évidemment le mouvement des jeunes et ce
moment où il se clôt dans l'elysée ou
alors où il va en voyage au maroc me
semble-t-il en allemagne en belgique ou
tantôt pour udine et du raid et des
lignes de tgv ou enfin pour rencontrer
les exilés fiscaux en belgique mais vous
jamais à aucun moment ils ne seront sur
un rond-point où ils ne rencontrent des
auxiliaires de vie sociale des
assistantes maternelles des intérimaires
est finalement bon moi je dois dire que
j'ai la manie de suivre le parcours des
manuels macron depuis qu'il est
secrétaire général de l'elysée donc ça
fait maintenant plusieurs années
depuis 2012 et d'accumuler de la
documentation sur lui et en
réfléchissant à son parcours on voit que
finalement à aucun moment il n'a eu une
relation avec les gens avec le peuple
avec les intérimaires
il ya eu en permanence une relation avec
l'oligarchie il a été élevé dans l'antre
soit bourgeois et je dirais que les
grilles du lycée la providence derrière
lesquels moi aussi j'ai grandi il ne les
a jamais franchie il est toujours resté
protégés par des institutions
s'adoraient abords étaient protégés par
le lycée henri iv puis sciences po puis
l'ena puis la commission attali puis
[Musique]
le secrétariat général de l'elysée par
dont il ya eu la banque rothschild
auparavant le ministère de l'économie
retour à l'elysée comme président et
finalement je dirais même
al'inverse des gens qui s'élève david
d'habitude de devenir président la
république en effet on nous disait qu'il
y avait un certain cursus honorum qui
faisait qu'on avait été maire on avait
été député
on a vu un certain nombre de fonctions
comme ça qui même quand on était bons
choix construisait à travers les
permanences parlementaires ou à travers
les offices hlm un certain nombre de
choses comme ça
une relation avec les gens normaux et
emmanuel macron n'a jamais eu ça et
finalement même on regarde il est en son
art c'est un art de la séduction
je crois que c'est emmanuel carrère donc
le plus grand romancier qui dit que
suivant emmanuel macron qui lui fait les
clins d'oeil et dui emmanuel macron
serait séduire une chaise et c'est vrai
qu'il a une capacité à séduire qui est
indubitable et il a successivement
séduit de toutes les personnes dans
l'oligarchie dont ils se disaient elles
pourront me rendre service c'est une île
a eu sur 20 ans une stratégie de
séduction l'oligarchie quoi c'est que
vous avez tous les deux grandi du côté
d'amiens
mais finalement vous êtes pas connu dans
la séance scolaire s'il y avait quelques
années d'écart entre emma même un croc
et vous allez y avait deux ans d'écart
donc jamais hors jeu je n'ai rencontré
emmanuel macron 1 à ce moment là la
première fois que je les rencontre et
c'est quand il était ministre de
l'économie
et j'étais arrivé sur une société qui
s'appelait échos place à l'assemblée
recul dans l'isère donc non dans la
vallée du grésivaudan près de grenoble
et les gars me disait ben voilà on est
en train de se faire bouffer par le
patron alors qu'on a un vrai marché ont
fait débarquer temps de l'aluminium pour
l'industrie agroalimentaire
ça pourrait marcher super bien mais on a
été repris par un actionnaire qui en
train de démolir on est écrit l'état de
courrier au ministère de l'économie nous
a jamais répondu
donc c'était à l'époque emmanuel macron
et puis finalement on a eu il ya un
conseiller qui a reçu le patron mais qui
nous syndicats nous salariés ne nous a
jamais reçus et donc finalement j'aurais
dû m'écouter de temps pour rester à
saint vincent de mercus vous avez pas
vous en sortir
ce qu'il faut c'est monté à paris donc
on est monté à paris on été voir macro
et c'est au moment où il venait d
une serveuse économie et donc il était
candidat en marche déjà à cette époque
là et c'est là qu'a eu lieu la première
rencontre avec les manuels mâcon sur un
mode d'interpellation du candidat en
l'humain mais comment ça se fait que
vous ayez jamais allé finalement il
s'est rendu dans lé dinh ce qui a donné
lieu pour christophe chevalier donc le
syndic elle rendra compte ajuster en en
vente libre c'est même des anecdotes sur
la machine à café sur sa façon de voir
comment les usines fonctionnent vous l
impression qui connaît pas grand chose
finalement à ce qu'il voit le sentiment
de christophe qui est le salarié ne le
point qui tente de monter une société
coopérative sait qu'il a affaire à
quelqu'un qui est complètement
déconnecté simplement de la réalité
c'est-à-dire qu'il lui donnait achetons
pour utiliser la machine à café
il sait pas utiliser la machine à café
il lui propose un tee shirt on lui
demande quelle est sa taille il sait pas
quelle est la taille
et puis il visite l'usiné on demande de
mâcon demande qu'est ce que c'est ça
comme machine bah c'est un tour pour
tourneur fraiseur
et eux ils séparent connaître à tous qui
pour christophe est vraiment le comble
quoi parce que il a su culture du ciel
mais surtout c'est le moment où au
ministère de l'économie
quand on lit le livre de christian
eckert qui était le collègues
socialistes d' emmanuel macron en tant
que ministre du budget à bercy on voit
que à ce moment là que fait emmanuel
macron il concentre toute son énergie
dans une stratégie toujours de séduction
l'oligarchie et il produit des des
dîners deux dîners par soir au ministère
de l'économie avec des gens très célèbre
des scieries d'eldar des bernard henri
lévy et dominique strauss kahn
bref c'est une stratégie de tisser sa
toile d'araignée pendant le temps où il
aurait dû se mettre au service du pays
et christian eckert formule en disant
c'est plus chic d'aller à las vegas fr
la french tech payés par les
contribuables ou de se faire payer des
dîners pour construire son parti que
d'intervenir pour une fonderie
l'aluminium
donc voilà dans ce temps où les salariés
déco places sont en train de crever la
gueule
on a un ministre de l'économie qui lui
frey avec le gotha en de multiples
dîners mondains et ça a été le coeur de
son activité ça c'est quelque chose que
je faisais mon idole un autre livre
justement le le fait que les manuels
macron ministre de l'économie durant les
derniers mois avant sa démission c'est
en fin août 2000 2016 il ya beaucoup de
temps de réception de personnes pour
vous ce temps il est utilisé pour pour
créer en off
là en l'occurrence c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est christian recchia tête je veux
dire c'est l'évidence même que toute son
énergie et canaliser là dedans mais
aussi l'argent public est canalisé là
dedans il a quasiment bouffer
l'intégralité des du budget du ministère
à ce moment là en huit mois parce que il
est il faisait des double din et ainsi
de suite donc il a mis toute son énergie
à temps mais même quand il était
ministre de l'économie
là on l'apprend d'une petite
biographique est plutôt glamour qui
s'appelle les maquereaux on apprend que
par exemple emmanuel macron manger une
fois par semaine chez bernard arnault
qui est l'homme le plus riche de france
le patron de lvmh du groupe carrefour
est surtout des écoles et du parisien
wihr c'est quand même pas rien de se
dire que le ministre de l'économie
socialiste
enfin d'un gouvernement socialiste avec
beaucoup dit m parenthèse mais quand
même
dean une fois par semaine chez la
principale fortune de france c'est une
relation là qui établit avec le lire si
je démontre il ya des services rendus à
lagardère il ya des services rendus à
bolloré il ya une relation de copains
c'est un décrit comme tel avec et xavier
niel
il y a la même chose avec bernard mourad
qui est le bras droit de patrick drahi
des services rendus également à patrick
dry bref martin bouygues aussi on a
cumulé des liens qui sont construits
soit par des services rendus avec de
l'argent public soit par des relations
régulières et généralement les deux qui
font que le liga il devient le je dirais
le jockey de l'oligarchie et en
particulier des patrons presse une
stratégie diriger très directement vers
les patrons presse qui vont décider de
miser sur le jockey emmanuel macron lui
prêtait le meilleur cheval de lui faire
faire de lui proposer des unes de
magazines de lui et de lui offrir des
entretiens de lui accorder des des
reportages régulier à 6,8 ce qui lui a
d'ailleurs françois bayroux quand même
qui est pas le plus gauchiste en la
matière qui parle d'une opération la con
il dit les grands intérêts financiers se
sont ligués pour mener une opération
c'est l'opération macro et lui
regrettait à l'époque c'était avant
qu'ils se mettent en cheville lui même
avec emmanuel macron il est vrai
quelques votes regretté que l'état soit
mis au service je vois la qualité
en fait ils disaient que c'étaient les
intérêts économiques qui maintenant
prenez le pas directement sur le pouvoir
politique
c'est ce qu'on voit sur mettre en oeuvre
avec avec emmanuel macron faisait ces
paroles que vous faites presque tout au
long du livre dans la construction du
personnage j'ai mal d'un compte sont à
son enfance et son adolescence jusqu'à
la fait qu'il devienne président de la
république ces liens que vous établissez
entre des personnes fortunées d'
influence et qui ont aussi une
importance dans le paysage médiatique en
fait je écrit je pense une espèce de
biographie non autorisée des manuels
macron reprenant étape par étape
son cursus et traçant mais je n'invente
rien c'est je lis les pages mais par
exemple quand en espérant en fait en
permanence qui va établir une relation
avec les gens que moi je croise depuis
20 ans que je suis reporter à haffa tire
donc les pays qui galèrent secours
populaire les auxiliaires de vie sociale
les assistantes maternelles zoubir qui
travaillent sur le chantier d'insertion
la citadelle d'amiens et je me demande
je me dis mais quand est ce qu'ils les
rencontres quand est ce qui les reçoit
quand est ce qu'il comprend ce que ça
veut dire le surendettement quand est ce
qu'il comprend ce que ça veut dire
boucler un budget avec le smic ou avec
le rsa enfin caisse quand est ce qu'il
comprend pas ce que signifie 5 euros
d'apl voies parallèles voilà est on
finalement dans son parcours il ne peut
pas comprendre ça parce qu'à aucun
moment où il est en symbiose en empathie
avec les gens avec le peuple avec les
classes populaires avec les ouvriers les
employés les chômeurs les retraités à
bas revenus par exemple quand il y a à
la préfecture de beauvais dans l'oise je
sais pas j'ai un espèce d'espoir ses
laitages hier à l'ena il fait son stage
à la préfectorale qui a un stage
traditionnel et je me dis bon à ce
moment-là peut-être qu'il va nouer une
relation avec les gens dans des
commissions science surendettement il va
y avoir quelqu'un qui va venir
l'interpeller sur un sujet il va sortir
en boîte de nuit avec il ou elle
et puis ça va devenir une amitié est
assis il aura une intuition du populaire
et qu'est-ce qui rend compte il
rencontre henry hermand qui est un grand
pas de citron la grande distribution qui
va tomber amoureux au sens paternelle de
d'emmanuel macron et qui va miser sur
lui qui va lui donner tous les moyens de
pénétrer les cercles de la gauche
chrétienne
pour kippour voilà jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie il va l'aider y compris
financièrement en payant son mariage en
leur finançant ses vacances à marrakech
et ainsi de suite
il est manuelle macron s'est dit dans un
papier du monde voit bien tout l'intérêt
mais y compris l'intérêt matériel qu'il
a à devenir ami avec henry hermand donc
il ya une vraie stratégie la de
construction de sautes de sa carrière
grâce à des amitiés intéressés quand on
ne peut pas être biographie non
autorisée comment vous avez pris contact
avec certaines personnes comment vous
avez construit je veux dire une des
citations c'est vrai je dois dire que
vous savez moi je pense que je vais me
la raconter mais je m'en fous non je
pense que j'ai écrit une pièce
littéraire quelque part donc il ya une
énorme documentation parce que ça fait
des années que je cumule la doc sur
emmanuel macron et après il ya une
espèce de g je sais pas j'essaie de me
laisser aller et d'imaginer ce que c'est
d'être dans la psychologie des manuels
mâcon qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
d'avoir été à la providence à henri iv à
sciences po et à l'ena
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'avoir était
adolescent adulé par tout le monde dans
son entourage par les hells et enfin ses
compagnons au lycée par par ses
enseignants d'être ado annulée comme ça
en permanence j'essaie de me mettre à sa
place et d'écrire le récit de destins
croisés avec ce troisième personnage
central avant la vie qui sont les gens
qui sont les français qui sont les gens
que je rencontre et qui ne le rencontre
pas quoi qui vous fait que pareil avec
votre vie à vous dire d'un côté où vous
fait le portrait d'un émail macron à qui
tout réussit tout le monde tombe déjà
aujourd'hui très vite très jeune et puis
d'un autre côté vous on a l'impression
que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué on
parle même de termes dépressif c'est des
termes assez fort on
il ramène de trajectoire différente à ce
moment là mais vous savez je crois que
même encore maintenant et ça c'est pour
le moins qu'on puisse dire mais je c'est
évident que moi j'ai un sentiment de
médiocrité régulier en particulier à
l'adolescence et jouer demande si je
vais m'en sortir un jour du sentiment
d'être nulle d'être une merde ne pas
trouver son chemin
où est ce qu'on va être valorisée qu'est
ce que est ce qu'il ya des gens qui vont
nous mfah tu vois je sais pas je pense
qu'il ya plein de jeunes qui traverse
cette phase là et il ya des gens qui
malheureusement il reste mais et comment
on passe au dessus pour vous alors ouais
je veux d'abord dire ce que ça apporte
parce que je pense que ça lui manque à
emmanuel macron ce que pour vous c'est
important de connaître ces difficultés
de se sentir médiocre et c'est important
de se souvenir et c'est important de
s'en souvenir mais en moi tu vois de
savoir ce que c'est que d'être fragile
ne pas croire qu'il suffit de traverser
la rue si on veut on peut
quand tu peux gagner on est on est des
winners non c'est pas vrai il ya une
fragilité dans le coeur de l'homme moi
j'ai une fragilité en moi tu vois il ya
des failles je sais que je peux chuté et
ça me donne la possibilité par
l'empathie de comprendre ce que les gens
vivent au delà de la situation
matérielle la difficulté à remplir un
frigo mais quand on se sent pas bien
dans sa peau quand on se demande si on
va trouver une place dans la société
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que d'arriver
dans une agence d'intérim et de se faire
jeter quasiment son cv ou de reposer le
cv sur la table ac v qui est à moitié
vide parce que tu as vingt ans que en
effet testage t'as vu malheur déjà en
trouver alors tu te trouver du boulot
bon il faut réussir à se mettre à la
place du mec qui vit ce à quoi les jeux
voir ce qu'il peut y avoir comme
violence en face est ce qu'on ressent
dans tous les propos d' emmanuel macron
dans cette arrogance qui perce quand
même régulièrement c'est qui est
l'incapacité de se mettre à la place
l'autre ils arrivent à se mettre à la
place des gens qui ont l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune a payé ou
qu'ils avaient la peau solidarité sur la
fortune a payé et voilà c'est une
calamité pour eux c'est bien difficile à
vivre et tout ça il arrive à compatir
avec ça ils n'arrivent pas à compatir
vraiment puissamment avec des gens qui
sont dans la galère matériel et mais
aussi dans la galère spirituelle qui
doute de même tu vois je pense que moi
j'ai une longue traversée du désert on
peut dire aimer aller elle m'a nourri et
je dirais notre différence je pense que
c'est ce qu'ils peuvent dans le livre le
faire au plus mal
emmanuel macron c'est je le revendique
j'ai une oeuvre j'ai une oeuvre tu vois
moi je place la rotule du pouvoir et
quand j'étais adolescent il y avait un
portrait de kavanagh dans ma chambre
il y avait une citation des proches il y
avait des dessins de vol à skis il y
avait une photo de renault il y avait la
photo de brel brassens ferré il y avait
importé de comptes d'era et j'aurais
voulu être un artiste et j'ai la chance
je me la raconte mais je m'en fous j'ai
la chance d'être devenu un artiste un
artiste qui fait la politique mais je
suis un artiste
je fais des films j'ai fait des
émissions de radio je produis des livres
et jeux constituent quoi pas je ne
prenais pas là juste du reportage je les
écris j'essaye d'avoir une langue
choisir mes mots
ça peut pas dire que c'est parfait tu
vois c'est un livre qui là pour le coup
est écrit très rapidement mais je
c'est en tant qu écrivain que je le fais
mais ces sentiments qui étaient les
vôtres à l'époque justement très on va
dire critiques à votre encontre ou d'un
état d'esprit
voilà dépressif et sait comment vous
l'avez surmonter est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez encore des symptômes de
l'époque doivent évidemment et je dirais
je m'applique à les avoir par moments je
m'applique à me souvenir l'homme fragile
c'est pas fragile je suis toujours mais
l'homme qui n'avait pas de valeur dans
la société qui n'était reconnu par
personne la c
que je viens de rentrer le la bouche de
métro ici je peux pas me la raconter
mais il ya deux personnes qui vont
saluer sur le trottoir et le mec il
passe un vélo qui m'a dit à rufin tu
vois mon bâton mieux ça fait du bien tu
as une reconnaissance je pense que la
reconnaissance pour étudier ça mais ça
produit juste la reconnaissance par les
autres tu vois c'est le sait la
principale calmes
si tu veux rien oui c'est évident en
s'éveillant je pense que même il doit y
avoir des hormones de la reconnaissance
ne s'est pas légaux finalement oui mais
moi toujours légaux moi j'ai toujours
j'ai de lego j'ai de l'orgueil
j'ai de l'ambition jeu j'espère et je
pense que c'est un une ambition de lui
saunière ce n'est pas l'ambition
autoroutière normal mais j'ai de
l'ambition je veux dire que tu fais pas
des films comme je fais tu ne portes pas
un truc un journal pendant 20 ans comme
je lé fais si t'as pas de l'orgueil de
l'ambition et de l'ego c'est évident
donc serbe après c'est à quoi tu mets un
service de quoi tu le mets est ce que
c'est juste une ambition normes et du
parcours où tu grimpes tu vois des des
strates les unes après les autres
voilà donc alors tu me demandais quand
même comment je les surmonter d'abord
j'ai beaucoup travaillé quand même tu
vois j'ai énormément écrit je pense que
j'ai écrit plusieurs milliers de pages
qui n'ont pas été publiés donc j'y
travaillais lelangue
et puis j'ai eu la chance de par le même
éditeur d'avoir mon premier livre les
petits soldats du journaliste qui a été
publiée qui a rencontré un certain
succès bon voilà mais je crois que je
m'en suis sorti par les gens il ya une
scène de la vie est belle de capra que
je cite pas dans le livre mais dans la
vie est belle et le héros c'est un
banquier méaban qui est honnête donc
avant-hier ruiné films de capra et un
soir il comme il est ruiné
il va arriver sa femme le quitte il
bourrer la gueule bistrot il construit
il sa voiture pomme
il envoie sa voiture dans un arbre il
envie de se suicider il grave sur un
pont et il est prêt à plonger dans la
mer
la rivière en dessous et là il ya son
nom qui apparaît c'est un ange de
troisième place qui a pas encore les les
ailes parce qu'il n'a jamais réussi à
sauver personnes et là on lange
il plonge dans l'eau à ce moment là le
banquier qu'est-ce qu'il fait saute
aussi et il ramène l'ange sur la rive
tu vas élan je lui dis à ta vu j'étais
bien sauver le héros est dénommée temps
tu racontes n'importe quoi c'est moi qui
vient de se sauver et la l'angine allant
jeter sauver en me laissant me sauver et
je crois que moi ce qui m'a sauvé c'est
ce qui me sauve encore ce sont les gens
ce sont les gens que j'aime mais quand
tu as de quelqu'un c'est toi même que tu
aides aussi et voilà je crois que
profondément c'est mon rapport aux gens
et je sais que quand je vais pas bien
tutorat te replier comme une tortue dans
sa carapace tu vois et moi il faut
trouver le moment où tu vas quand même
réussir à sortir de toi et sortir de
chez toi
elle allait rencontrer des gens qui vont
se rencontrer leur histoire tu vas
essayer de ti mêlée et c'est ça qui va
me sauver voilà et c'est comme ça que je
me sauve depuis 20 ans donc voilà vous
avez pas de l'ambition aussi quelque
part oui il y en a beaucoup dans les
commentaires qui parlent de votre avenir
à plus long terme chez que notamment à
la fin du livre vous avez parlé d'un
projet pour des droits du livre d'un
projet pour préparer autre chose
il ya certains qui vous voit pourquoi
pas être une alternative à gauche même
pour 2022 parlons loin mais qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous en conseille
franchement est ce que ça peut être une
possibilité watts en tout cas cette
obsession je vis aujourd'hui je vis et
je publie ce livre maintenant et je fais
je veux du soleil maintenant les geôles
diffuse maintenant parce que je veux
qu'ils aient des choses qui arrivent
maintenant tu vois je veux que moi je
suis plus un homme de mouvement social
et j'aimerais que le 17 novembre qu'on a
eu cet automne il reconnu en ce
printemps
donc selon moi j'espère que mon nom
restera dans l'histoire de la gauche
tu vois pour dire les choses comme ça ça
fait partie de mon orgueil mon ambition
qui reste par des livres par départ des
films qui reste aussi par la création au
mouvement social
et si jamais il pouvait y avoir un
aimant ce boom
ce printemps je sais le truc qui me
rendrait le plus heureux donc je reste
dans tout ça est ce que député
finalement ce n'est pas un rond
peut-être pas assez élevé non mais tu
vas messieurs pouvoir faire bouger les
choses mais c'est pas mieux
ben moi je savais ce que ce puisque
j'aurai comme possibilités comme député
c'est un rôle de tribunes je savais que
c'est pas l'action législative de toute
façon il faut que tout le monde le sache
ça n'est pas à l'assemblée que se fait
la loi
c'est du bidon c'est du bidon la loire
c'est les désirs du président s'est
construit techniquement par les
ministères et c'est validé par
l'assemblée mais c'est un rôle de
validation de la loi
donc je savais très bien que ça serait
pas là dessus de juin si je passe un
amendement ou sa cave en demandant la
totalité de mon mandat ça sera le mieux
mais je les dis d'emblée à mes électeurs
dans dans ma circonscription je leur ai
dit je vous promets pas la lune je vous
promets qu'un truc je ne courberont pas
l'échiné
finalement c'est plus une visibilité oui
c'est sûr c'est une visibilité ces jeux
ne comblerait pas les shins et espérer
un phénomène de contagion que en se
disant bon la revue phare il a fait ça
il ya un style tu sais je pense que je
suis en train de proposer un style ça ne
pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas d'autres
styles et puis ça mais un style c'est le
style c'est l'homme bon bah voilà il ya
un style peut-être que il y aura
d'autres personnes qui ont envie de
bouleverser cette assemblée ou d'autres
assemblées ou de s'impliquer
politiquement parce que j'aurai produit
une contagion l'espèce de libération tu
vois libération de la parole la manière
dont je parle je pense que ça s'entend
aussi je veux pas mais c'est son chalet
ouais tu vois je suis je n'ai pas appris
à faire de la langue de bois j'ai pas
envie d'apprendre même si ça vous fout
pas mal de désagréments
et justement sans langue de bois ça peut
pas bien sûr d'avoir tout l'ambition que
la vôtre aujourd'hui
justement c'est de faire bouger les
choses dans le pays c'est infiniment des
prisons de la république
non enfin moi en tout cas je sais que
aujourd'hui je ne veux pas de ce
président mais je veux pas de président
vous ne voudrez pas avoir simplement non
je veux pas sa place tu sais que je
pense que pour parler de mélenchon ou de
macron deux hommes que pour lequel j'ai
pas du tout la même estime je passe mon
avis une question mais je n'envie pas
leur place je dire il faut voir que le
pouvoir c'est quelque chose qui en ferme
moi je le vis déjà comme député tu vois
j'ai moins de temps à consacrer aux gens
sans parler de mes enfants tu vois j'ai
moins de temps à consacrer aux gens et
c'est l'espèce d'échappée que j'arrive à
faire tu vois alors hier je suis allé
voir les restos du coeur à viña goût
puis après je suis allé rencontré katia
pour qu'elle me raconte comment ça
s'était passé sa séparation
parce que c'est pas vrai que toute
époque fait du côté des forces de police
des assistantes sociales toutes les
institutions pour permettre aux femmes
qui sont mal et qui sont mal y compris
en prenant des couleurs enfants pour se
séparer de leur mari enfin ce schisme
entre la réalité et la théorie de
marlène schiappa dans l'hémicycle donc
voilà et je fais je vais du soleil en
six jours dans une espèce de tu vois ne
pas de brèche que j'ouvre dans mon
agenda
donc je vois déjà comment ça me renferme
la ministère c'est encore des murs qui
sont plus épais avec les gens que tu vas
et donc s'effacer comme en gardant un
groupe parlementaire comme jean luc
mélenchon ou dans un an
non mais tu sais j'ai envie pas du tout
jean-luc je lui ai dit pour rire mais
enfin c'est pas tant pour rire que ça
j'espère qu'il va pas me piquer ma place
parce que moi j'arrive à jouir d'une
immense liberté tu vois quand même tu
vois là je disparais pendant 3 mois 0
médias je continue mon travail quand
même dans l'hémicycle un peu en retrait
faut le dire mais
mais pour écrire un bouquin pour faire
un film jean luc mélenchon il n'a pas
cette chance
moi j'ai cette chance tu vois c'est que
je cite dans le livre le la fable de la
fontaine le loup et le chien
moi j'espère ne pas avoir de collier je
veux pas de collier je veux pouvoir
courir courir et courir encore coiffure
parlons justement de son patin de cette
déconnexion dans le livre justement il
ya cette idée par rapport aux fins de
mois où vous avez le fait que les mâles
mâcon les votes plusieurs fois pour vous
c'est un cliché des années 70 vous dites
maintenant la fin de mois ça n'existe
plus elle commence le 9
c'est à dire qu'on est dans une
situation qui est beaucoup plus
préoccupante aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était peut-être il ya 30 ou 40 ans et
puis au delà de ça c'est pour être des
fins de match et que vous l'avez
beaucoup illustré dans votre livre
justement de par sa situation
personnelle dans ces personnes
j'en ai très faibles ressources allawi
qui sont peut-être aussi à l'image de ce
qu'on peut voir au sein du mouvement des
filets jaunes est toujours bon c'est
vrai que quand macro effet son discours
là tu vois c'est le 9 décembre je crois
avec les mains comme ça l'a un peu
statue de cire au musée grévin
tu te souviens de bons et on voit qu'à
un moment ils essaient de dire je les ai
vus ces femmes de courage sur les
ronds-points qui peine à finir leur fin
à leur leur moi mon côté on sent que
c'est pas vécu que c'est pas habiter
chez lui que bon voilà ces éléments de
langage il faut le mettre dedans il les
a pas tellement vu sur les rangs point
ces femmes de courage
bon voilà et c'est vrai que moi je n'ai
pas entendu pendant la traversée de la
france
les pannes moi parce qu'on est passé à
autre chose tu vois on n'est passé que
le 15 du mois c'est déjà la galère le 9
du mois c'est déjà la galère on la
situation elle s'est durcie par rapport
à ça c'est massifier juste te dire
pourquoi j'ai moi aussi tout accroché au
mouvement des jeunes
bon d'abord parce qu'il ya un côté bar
et non un côté inattendu
tu vois ça sort du cadre c'est un truc
qui se lance sur facebook les gens ils
décident
revêtir des chasubles jaunes d'aller
occuper des ronds-points ne pas quitter
le truc le samedi soir d'aller sur les
champs-elysées bon c'est un truc barré
et donc c'est vrai qu'il ya pas mal de
gens à gauche dans les syndicats tout ça
si ça sort du cadre soeur va pas moi je
veux dire que c'est parce que ça sort du
cadre que ça me va il y avait déjà une
espèce d'esthétique qui me plaisait mais
surtout tu sais les gens que j'ai
croisés là ce sont les mêmes que j'ai vu
pendant 20 ans sauf que pendant vingt
ans ça se chuchoter dans leur cuisine
le frigo à moitié vide le la peine à
mettre son enfant en centre de vacances
parce qu'on n'a pas les ronds et payé à
la mairie
l'impossibilité de partir en vacances
baffe la difficulté à accéder à un
espèce de bonheur confort mais ça se
chuchotait avec honte et le mouvement
des jeunes pour moi c'est ce temps où on
passe de la honte privé à la colère
publique et moi quand je voyais les gens
dans chez eux c'était fallait changer
leur prénom ou alors mettez des
initiales fallait surtout pas prendre de
photos encore moins à filmer et là ça a
été le moment du grand déballage ou sur
les ronds points
on venait passer je le dis de la banque
privée à la colère publique on venait
passer du silence au à la revendication
on veut dépasser de l'invisibilité à
l'hyper visibilité avec un gilet jaune
fluorescent bon donc c'était ce temps où
on sortait de chez soi et on sortait de
soi aussi un temps de libération la
parole donc c'est vrai que moi j'ai
trouvé ça extraordinaire quoi et c'est
pour ça que j'ai voulu
aussitôt arrivé avec moi c'était un
stylo mais j'espérais vous voulez la
caméra ces chiffres le film avec un
espèce de sismographes de ça donc c'est
pour ça que je pense que on a vécu un
moment extraordinaire dans notre
histoire de france qui continue dont
j'espère qu'il va y avoir une résurgence
importante ce printemps et qui à nouveau
on va voir ce qui était des isolés c'est
à dire les auxiliaires de vie sociale
les auto entrepreneurs les assistantes
maternelles les personnes handicapées
tout c'est tout ces gens que d'habitude
on voit jamais qu'ils se mettent à venir
ensemble sur les ronds-points c'était
très beau il sait vous l'évoquez aussi
dans votre livre par rapport à la
confiscation de la parole médiatique ou
léo qu'elle fait que c'était plus des
gens riches fortunes et qu'ils avaient
intentées
des primes notamment une france inter à
comment comment ça se fait que d'un seul
coup à wallace ce murs est franchie
personne n'avait vu venir finalement ce
qui sait ce qui s'est passé non bah
ouais là faisant même d'un point de vue
politique même ceux qui sont sur le
terrain aujourd'hui qui suivent ces
mouvements sociaux n'ont pas vu venir ce
mouvement-là gilet jaune et c'est cette
récupération de la parole médiatique qui
était à vous en faites état dans votre
livre avec peut-être un temps de parole
de 5 à 10% d'un foyer général j'ai posé
la question ce matin puisqu'il ya
l'étude du csa donc du conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel qui vient d'être rendue
et qui dit que le les csp + dans les
informations aux 88 % du temps d'antenne
ça veut dire qu'il reste 12 % pour les
retraités les chômeurs les ouvriers les
employés c'est à dire pour l'immense
majorité du pays dont et les gilets
jaunes ont été ce temps extraordinaire
aussi où ils se retrouvent sur les
plateaux télé pour des mauvaises raisons
aussi c'est à dire que ça fait lundi
matin bfm s'est rendu compte que quand
il y avait des gens normaux qui
apparaissait finalement les
représentants ordinaire qui arrivent
avec leur langue tout fait ou les
experts d'un moment ça fait suer les
gens et entendre des gens qui ont un
langage beaucoup plus normale qui parle
comment ils vivent dans l'hôpital du
camion qui conduisent de leur frigo
bah finalement cet ordinaire là il fait
de l'audimat donc quelque part pour de
mauvaises raisons mais il ya eu une
forte présence des régies les jeunes cet
automne après pourquoi il ya eu les
gilet jaune
moi je me souviens que j'avais lu le
bouquin de david dufresne qui s'appelait
je crois deux heures avec brel je suis
un fan de jacques brel
donc il a écrit un livre sur vesoul en
fait c'est est-ce que brel était allé à
vesoul skis et pamela vesoul comment il
est
l'idée de chanter vesoul bon et en fait
je pense que quelque part il y avait
déjà rapporté la france qui allait
devenir gilet jaune mais surtout à
l'intérieur il avait eu cette phrase
comment un président peut-il parler aux
pauvres d'un poignon de dagne sans
rendre les pauvres d'agnes mais
finalement si quand même il les a rendus
derrière le point de départ de chez les
jeunes je dire c'est macron démission
c'est quand même ça a été le grand
fédérateur de l'automne parce que il a
ajouté l'injustice
comment ne pas voir la violence quand on
décide de supprimer la pause solidarité
de la fortune 5 milliards d'euros pour
les plus riches de ce pays qui ont vu
leur fortune multipliée par sept en
ratant brc y vont quand même plutôt bien
et de l'autre côté aller gratter 5 euros
d'apl allait supprimer les contrats
aidés à les imposer la csg aux retraités
bon il ya une évidence de même si c'est
tellement criants et ça fait avec
arrogance sur le thème les gens qui ne
sont rien les gaulois réfractaires et
puis tout ça à un moment c'est au delà
de la difficulté à vivre
c'est une forme de dignité qui est
blessé chez les gens c'est irrévocable
respect respectez-nous au moins vous
êtes notre président respecté nous et je
pense que c'est ça qui était un
déclencheur c'était donc c'est parti sur
le gasoil mais moins dès le 17 novembre
on voyait que c'était pas le gasoil
c'était le social de manière beaucoup
plus générale quoi après moi ce que je
remets dans tout ça c'est la destruction
des groupes ont un point jeu que je
d'accueil l'ordre à partir de fin
décembre lorsque c'est catastrophique
parce que enfin je comprends du point
vue le pouvoir il a raison le pouvoir
parce que en fin de compte c'était le
lieu où se retisser du lien les gens ils
venaient là pour revendiquer pour
distribuer les papiers pour bloquer un
peu mais ils venaient aussi pour se
retrouver pour partager un café parce
qu'il en avait marre on le raconte de
d'être devant leur télé ou devant leur
console
vidéo tout seul quoi et donc c'était le
lieu où seront conçus et le lien et le
pouvoir a fait le choix avec des
buldozers et avec des matraques des
forces de l'ordre d'évacuer la le mode
de protestation le plus pacifique et je
dirais même enfantin construire des
cabanes en bois aller récupérer les
portes à droite et tout ça avec un vrai
savoir-faire populaire allait rajouter
une cuisine enfin voilà il y avait tout
ça et ce savoir-faire populaire et
enfantin le pouvoir la casse et il a
cassé le lieu où se reconstruise et le
lien parce que le pouvoir raison c'est
que quand les gens se mettent ensemble
quand ils commencent à se parler quand
ils commencent à se rassembler c'est en
effet une menace pour l'ordre et donc de
ce point de vue là il a raison
maintenant il faut plus qu'il nous parle
de retisser du lien social
tu vois j'entends les
ministres-présidents des sociologues des
économistes des philosophes dire qu'il
faut retisser du lien social à l'endroit
où ce lien se retisser ils n'ont détruit
maintenant j'ai conduit votre livre j'ai
vu aussi justement le rejet du
personnage que vous avez des macros où
vous dites même page 44 c'est physique
c'est viscéral
c'est très mal très mal même honte
quelque part oui mais voilà j'ai un g1
roger physique viscérale vue du
personnage et vous pensez qu'il ya des
millions de personnes qui le pur souci
ça pour vous voilà il ya vraiment au
delà de ce qu'un de cette personne au
delà de ses idées de ses pensées il ya
aussi quelque chose qui va son physique
oui alors il ya plusieurs choses d'abord
je suis on replace le passage dans le
contact général je dis bien que je suis
pas fier de cette réflexion là mais que
maintenant quand maxime bouet mais comme
je suis quelqu'un de sincère de toute
façon les corps il parle le mon visage
il en train de parler la manière dont
mes mains bougent en tentant de parler
mon physique parle on parle on dégage
quelque chose de social
au delà de seul mot ou une solide et
qu'on prononce donc voilà je ce qu'il ya
chez makro sa a coté maîtres de
l'univers j'évoque ce roman de tom wolfe
le bûcher
les vanités où les traders de new york
ont le sentiment d'être un peu les
maîtres de l'univers et il porte sa dans
leur corps et je pense qu'il ya un côté
comme ça quand on voit emmanuel macron
sûr de lui en permanence
quand tu es pas sûr de toi tu commences
à te mais je faut dire aussi que plus
loin jeudi mais j'ai tort de penser
comme ça ces sondes et a priori il faut
pas penser avec ses a priori la rejetons
les donnons lui sa chance
voyons bien ce qu'il fera et ensuite les
actes traduisent quand même qui va
constamment se placer du côté de
l'oligarchie plutôt que du côté de la
démocratie quoi mais après moi je c'est
un livre je revendique comme étant un
ouvrage de littérature c'est à dire où
je viens oui parler franchement de ce
que je peux ressentir et qui n'est pas
toujours ce qu'il ya de plus glorieux
mais je pense que tu vois la manière on
établit le souhaite que tu as choisi la
tab armes là aujourd'hui ton oeil qui
pétillent non mais voilà un peu ton rire
la manière de rire du tout ça ça dégage
quelque chose qui est une personnalité
qui est qui et relève de l'appartenance
de classe et bah y'a des gens ça
s'apprend pas tu vas s'apprend pas et je
pense que oui je suis pas le seul mais
après je dis bien je suis pas fier de ce
réflexe là et voyons voyons ce qui va
donner comme la d'époque cette époque là
comme secrétaire général de l'elysée
jeudi bon bah si ça se trouve c'est lui
qui va être la courroie de transmission
et qui va permettre à l'elysée de faire
entrer les pays guy leymarie les oublis
relais cindy les auxiliaires de vie
sociale les intérimaires les amener au
président de la république de l'époque
françois hollande pour qu'ils écoutent
ce que veut le peuple ou bien quelles
sont ses souffrances et que c'est par
emmanuel macron que ça passe et bah non
c'est pas du tout ça qui se passe
laurence parisot et tous les autres le
raconte au contraire il était le canal
par lequel tous les dirigeants du cac 40
passé pour imposer leur leurs vues à
commencer par le pacte de responsabilité
le crédit impôt compétitivité emploi
bref il a il
le fait que hollande même une politique
de droite sur le plan économique et
social
c'est largement dû à emmanuel influence
ah oui il fait basculer je veux dire il
ya hollande il n'était pas férocement à
gauche c'est clair mais il est évident
que à tous les moments
emmanuel macron a pesé pour que l'on
aille vers plus de libéralisme pouvoir
vous travers le roman ou fin le récit
que vous faites on a l'impression que et
malingre ont finalement été presque déjà
regarde semi président mais qui avaient
déjà une influence énorme sur la
politique du président de l'époque
en tout cas je pense qu'ils avaient ils
avaient une influence il était à
l'oreille un peu molle de françois
hollande qui avait d'autres personnes
que tu veux dire quand macron a été
remplacé il a été remplacé par des
personnes qui venaient d'y remplacer
quelqu'un qui avait été chez rothschild
aussi il a été remplacé par des gens qui
venaient ces puces et merrill lynch
barclays ou n'apporte met enfin en
espèces de fusion entre deux voies de
passage en permanence entre les grandes
banques et
et le secrétariat général de l'elysée ou
de bercy fin c'est comme si elle avait
un mode d'appartenance de la casse un
peu uniforme ou les banques d'affaires
ont été les dirigeants politiques du
pays qu'ils soient de droite ou gauche
c'est fusionnel quoi vous la
communication du président le fait
justement qui va pas parler aux gens
sans qu'ils aient les caméras autres
dernièrement il ya une séquence qui a
fait beaucoup réagir c'est celle de
d'émail mâcon dans le présent est
maraude
alors on n'a pas su tout de suite parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de journée ce qui a
été conviée il ya des images qu'on futé
ensuite viennent photos rares de
l'elysée finalement cette séquence là ça
vous inspire quoi
ce que je tiens beaucoup emmanuel macron
grandi et il grandit politiquement en
milieu protégé tout son parcours se fait
dans des institutions il ya qu un seul
moment où et c'est un moment important
où il va franchir ça et aller davantage
vers les gens et par exemple chez
whirlpool à amiens mais c'est pendant la
campagne présidentielle et aujourd'hui
comme président la république maintenant
il faut faire attention à ce que dit
emmanuel macron il dit je vais au
contact c'est son expression permanente
c'est au contact au contact au contact
la communication l'alizé elle répète ce
au contact macron lui-même fin bon voilà
c'est l'expression consacrée
que veut dire aux contacts aux comptes
axa veut d'abord dire quelque chose qui
est juste à forme la plus primitive la
plus primaire de communication à jeu je
renvoie aux fonctions de romane jacobson
sur le langage mais le conte accès on
touche
et puis on va ailleurs quoi et signalant
le contact ça n'est que le début de
l'échangé normalement et on n'échange
plus longuement suite mais emmanuel
macron à quelqu'un qui quand il va vers
les gens va au contact c'est bref et aux
contacts ça peut induire aussi du heures
il est fier de dire que il va finalement
comme un boxeur entre sur les rings
heurter les gens parce qu'il faut pas
les caresser dans le sens du poil
voilà son rapport aux gens et la
marronne relève de ça est-ce que l'une
des personnes qu'il a croisé dans la
marronne va désormais venir toutes les
semaines à l'elysée
prendre l'apéro avec lui pour lui
expliquer sa vision du monde
les difficultés qu'il a à trouver un
logement pourquoi ils trouvent pas de
travail voilà tu vois il ya le contact
se posent à la relation à ce moment là
et évidemment autant il est au contact
un peu parfois des gens normaux autant
il en relation en lien permanent avec
l'oligarchie avec bernard arnault avec
qui il dîne une fois par semaine avec
bernard mourad qui était le bas droit du
bras droit de patrick drahi bfm rmc et
qu'il appelle mon lapin qui lui envoie
des textos permanent avec xavier niel
qui est son copain et je sais plus
dînent ensemble deux fois par semaine
xavier niel qui est marié à delphine
arnault la fille de bernard avec bernard
arnault la brigitte macron a été la prof
des enfants de bernard arnault donc on a
un milieu comme ça assez fusionnelle ou
là on n'est pas au contact
un petit coup comme ça avec des tweets
qui apparaissent mais oh on aimerait que
y ait les mêmes photos les mêmes tweets
moi j'ai demandé aujourd'hui en
commission des affaires économiques là
sur la loi pacte qu'on ait un registre
des lobbys et un registre des visiteurs
de l'elysée qu'on sache qui vient rendre
visite à emmanuel macron semaine après
semaine
et là on n'est plus dans le contact on
est dans la relation suivie dans les
liens il faut comprendre que pour moi il
faut aller au delà du évident qu'il ya
eu des services qui ont été rendus à
emmanuel macron le plus concret des
services et le financement de sa
campagne à coups de chèque de 7500 euros
avec une condition c'est enlever nos
lits sf
mais au-delà de ces services matériels
rendu par l'oligarchie
il faut bien voir que emmanuel macron a
construit des liens permanents et des
liens se sont aussi des liens affectifs
mille liens affectifs avec l'oligarchie
par ces rencontres par ces dîners par la
fréquentation de serre pendant nommé à
certains l'auront le collège des
bernardins et ainsi de suite
ce milieu là est ensemble et ses mille
liens affectifs et que de toute façon il
serait incapable de mener une politique
tiré contre les
et de ses proches du milieu dans lequel
il baigne
il ya une scène dans mon film dans notre
film avec j'espérais jouer du soleil ou
j'interroge amer jeudi si j'étais mâcon
qu'est ce que vous me diriez et le maire
me dis ben pourquoi vous avez supprimé
les sf les riches y vous aurez pas
embêtés en tout cas elle vous aurez
moins en mettait clé gilet jaune et
c'est un passage leader dès lors on
filme avec lequel je suis pas d'accord
parce que je pense que foncièrement les
riches
s'il n'avait pas supprimé l'isf lui
aurait fait sans doute beaucoup plus de
mal parce qu'ils sont beaucoup plus de
proches de lui parce qu'il possède des
médias à ce qu'ils encerclent la stilo
tonight parce que ce sont des relations
affectives lui aurait fait beaucoup plus
de mal que les gilet jaune qui sont un
peu éloignés à qui on peut envoyer les
policiers les flashs vol les bd les
grenades deux ans de désencerclement les
bulldozer enfin voilà donc au fond les
jeunes qui sont assez lointain emmanuel
macron vont lui pour une capacité de
nuisance qui est nettement inférieur à
un groupe de 50 cents personnes 500
personnes qui forment l'entourage le
plus proche du chef de l'état
alors vous évoquez juste 11 ans lille le
fait que voilà emmanuel macron poussé
françois hollande vers la droite que
vous dites justement ça se mérite la
gauche sont des combats et des fêtes une
longue citation qui évoque cela
finalement pour vous françois ruffin
qu'est-ce que d'être de gauche
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est être avec les
gens tu vois c'est clair c'est choisir
marie contre dry c'est choisir cindy
contre bolloré
enfin voilà pour moi c'est ça c'est
clair que c'est sur une échelle qui est
plus haut bas
et de tout faire pour que les maris et
cindy les ou lire les ait droit au
bonheur dans ce pays qui a jamais été
aussi riche
les gens ils doivent avoir le droit au
bonheur tu vois c'est ça pour moi c'est
la continuité du front populaire mon on
a eu les premiers congés payés pas
comment ça se fait que dans notre pays
il ya des gamins
tu vois qu'ils peuvent pas jouer au foot
quoi qu'ils peuvent pas aller samedi
après-midi j'en ai encore rencontrer là
qu'ils peuvent pas laisser mon bras
contre sabathia j'étais à marseille tu
vois on raconte que des gamins et
j'avais trois gamins en face de moi des
quartiers nord de marseille
ils peuvent pas ils ont pâti on leur
permet pas exempt pas de club pour jouer
au foot ils ont pas de pognon ils ont
pas de piscine il a ça une piscine sur
un terrain de foot
l'été qui est une piscine une espèce de
piscines gonflables
voilà je dire voilà mon engagement tu
sais moi je suis assez mauvais sur le
plan théorique sur le plan abstrait par
exemple c'est quelque chose qui je pense
nous complète entre jean luc mélenchon
et moi et jean luc mélenchon qui a une
formation de philosophe parle pas mal de
la théorie et il aboutit aux situations
concrètes et moi celle inverse
j'ai une très faible capacité
d'abstraction je me considère pas comme
quelqu'un d'intelligent
parce que je sais que le lycée à partir
du moment où ça devenait des idées un
peu abstraite je décrochais que tu vas
et tu mets ça fait ma force
parce que du coup je pars toujours du
réel du reportage des situations
concrètes de visages de gens je sais
pour qui je me bats et de pour dévoiler
des visages des noms des décors et
et ensuite à partir de ça je m'élève en
dix ans ont passé telles mesures qu'il
faut répondre mais ça coince à tel
endroit parce qu'elle telle politique
depuis trente ans enfin voila j'ai un
mouvement qui part du bas et petit monde
vers le haut donc je vais avoir du mal à
te définir la gauche mais bon et puis
après c'est quand même une tradition
historique je veux dire je fais mien
l'héritage de la révolution française je
fais mien la commune je fais venir un
jour s je fais mien le front populaire
je fais mien le conseil national de la
résistance je fais mien mai 68 je fais
mien aussi
mais 80 enfin voila je suis dans une
filiation comme ça historique je me sens
le dans un courant du coût est de droite
alors ce serait bien si tu sais ma est
le slogan de la campagne alors bon on va
dire que je suis manichéen mais là là
c'est la réalité qui est manichéenne
pour moi mais moi c'était ils ont ils
ont l'argent nous avons les gens puis
voie de droite c'est mener une politique
pour l'argent en gros un médecin
macron il dépasse même le truc de la
droite traditionnelle
il faut comprendre ça que son absence d'
ancrage local
son absence de lien avec les gens le
fait qu'il ait été dans cette bulle et
qui soit apparu comme un phénomène
politico médiatique immédiat fait qu' il
ya même des mesures de droite que jamais
un gouvernement de droite ne répliquent
the je pense à deux mesures par exemple
la suppression des contrats emploi
solidarité qui est une catastrophe
alors moi je suis jeune j'ai du jus
contre ces contrats précaires à que les
choses soient claires c'est évidemment
pas la panacée
c'est une béquille pour les gens mbeki
c'est déjà mieux que tu pries mais la
béquille qui écroulent et vous par terre
et bon j'ai vu les gens durer pendant
des années et des années
dans ces contrats là donc c'est pas la
solution mais les supprimer c'est pas la
solution plus c'est pas ce n'est pas la
solution pour les gens c'est pas la
solution pour les associations c'est pas
la solution pour un certain nombre de
municipalités
c'était une décision que un gouvernement
de droite traditionnelle n'aurait pas
pris the est pas prise avec cette
brutalité première première décision est
la deuxième décision c'est par exemple
ce qui s'est passé
sur les aides au logement des offices
hlm elle est taillée dans le budget des
offices hlm chez moi dans ma
circonscription
très concrètement ça a des conséquences
sur amiens est sûre à vivre en termes de
construction de logements sociaux en
termes de rénovation de l'habitat voilà
sa déconstruction des conséquences
qu'ils commettent est un mec de droite
normal qu'ils seraient passés par maire
de sa ville responsable assure une
société fille sache et avec tout ça il
n'aurait pas pris une décision comme ça
parce qu'il aurait su que ça allait
nuire à la fois aux offices et ensuite
aux locataires et aux plus modestes quoi
donc je pense que le fait de le
décrochage des manuels mac ronde avec le
pays
il fait qu'il ya des décisions qui sont
prises qui dépasse le strict de
l'appellation droite aimé e pour élargir
au delà de la figure des manuels macron
il faut bien voir que emmanuel macron
est juste l'incarnation d'une hyper
classe qui a décroché d'avec le pays
quoi qui se vit comme étant avec le
monde qui n'a plus de dates h
géographique qui eux mêmes se séparent
et moralement du reste de la nation
alors il reste encore quelques minutes
ensemble françois ruffin je salue tous
ceux qui n'ont rien actuellement vous
êtes très très nombreuses que cela
n'hésitez pas encore une fois elle
commenté le partager et puis dans les
dernières minutes on prendra quelques
tendances aussi au niveau des hauts
niveaux des questions ce qui revenait
aussi dans les commentaires alors il y
avait sur votre votre ambition pour la
suite vous n'avez certains voilà qui
poussé par rapport à 2022 mais aussi
d'autres questions par rapport au
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune qui a
commencé depuis le 17 novembre dernier
presque donc quatre mois de mobilisation
maintenant finalement que faire pour
faire bouger les choses c'est un peu la
question que se posent les gilet jaune
actuellement qui vont se mobiliser
samedi pour le 17e samedi consécutif
comment réussir aujourd'hui à enclencher
un rapport de force comment faire bouger
ligue quand on sait que maintenant
depuis le début de ce grand débat à mi
janvier c'est un peu d'un côté le grand
débat vous posera une question de suez
après il a un côté le grand débat puis
d'un autre côté mâle et gym qui continue
à maintenir
d'abord moi je crois qu'il faut signaler
ce qui a déjà été gagné parce que si on
dit aux gens qui perdent tout le temps
ça passe pas ce qui va leur donner envie
de se bouger
donc il ya une victoire matériel quand
même déjà moi il ya un avocat d'affaires
qui est venu me voir et qui m'a présenté
tu vois qui est plutôt côté gilet jaune
et il ya comme ça des années au mali
sociale et je pense que je suis aussi
quelque part peut-être une anomalie
sociale et donc il est venu me voir il
m'a montré le budget 2010 9 avant les
jets les jeunes tout le monde perdait
sauf les 1% qui gagnait énormément on a
il me montrait le budget 2010 9 après le
mouvement des chemises jaunes
on avait un est rééquilibrage avec tout
le monde qui gagnent un peu pas beaucoup
mais un peu et les 1% qui gagne aussi
rassure toi mais on avait déjà eu
quelque chose qui matériellement s'était
passé et puis il ya une très grande
victoire spirituel macron a quand même
mis à genoux à terre cet automne il ya
eu un coup d'arrêt a mis à l'oligarchie
sinon la réforme des retraites la
réforme du chômage à 7,8 sur et sans
doute mené avec davantage de brutalités
et là il ya un espèce de gel de la
situation donc voilà il faut quand même
signaler que c'est pas comme si ça
n'avait servi à rien pour moi ça d'ores
et déjà grandement servi maintenant ce
qu'il faut espérer ce printemps c'est
que liait d'apposer à l'horizon et qui
permettent de canaliser les forces à
nouveau comme l'a été le 17 novembre et
l'agacement il ya le 16 mars il ya le 16
mars il faut évident et évidemment
poussé au 16 mars pour que on est du
monde à paris et à lyon qui a un point
de rassemblement très important aussi
dans le sud de la france donc donc deux
points sur la même journée donc
justement voilà il ya d'un côté ce grand
débat je sais pas si vous l'avez regardé
un petit peu si vous en avez un
i non mais le jeu alors en termes de
communication ou de marketing mais ça
fait partie de la politique je crois que
le mouvement de gilet jaune a rouvert à
l'imaginaire politique cet automne je le
disais avec le gie donnée le le fait
qu'on quitte pas le rond point qu on y
construisent des cabanes enfin c'était
tellement original que ça rouvre un
imaginaire politique il faut admettre
que emmanuel macron avec son grand débat
et avec sa forme d'apparition comme ça à
bourg de péage ou ainsi de suite a
inventé une forme qui fait qu' il ya
quelque part repris la main sur le
terrain de l'as comme quoi donc
hélas comme c'est de la politique en soi
donc ce que je vois c'est évidemment sur
le fond un débat extrêmement cadré
encadré avec l'impossibilité de remettre
la peau dessus de zéro en cause la
suppression de l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune
on te demande si il faut reculer l'âge
de la retraite bref tout ça est très
téléguidés pour arriver à des
conclusions en macro nist de hadda point
de départ qui est les jeunes qu'il
n'était pas tellement voire même on te
dit que le rsa il mais il faudra une
contrepartie au rsa c'est une l'un d'eux
truc qui serait révoquée par les gilet
jaune par le par le grand débat pardon
il faudrait une contrepartie au rsa etc
ce qui sortirait je veux dire je vais
surtout les ronds points que j'ai vu
j'ai pas vu une seule personne me dire
il faudrait quand même que ceux qui
touchent le rsa il donne contrepartie
c'est pas ça c'est qu'elle est la
contrepartie pour le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi 40 milliards
d'euros qu'elle est la contrepartie pour
la suppression de l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune 5 milliard d'ot et là on
te pose pas de questions sur les
contreparties donc on a à d un débat qui
est très encadrée bon mais au-delà de ça
quand on connaît un peu le
fonctionnement des manuels macron c'est
quand même pas la première fois qu'il
fait le coup en marche s'est fondée là
dessus c'est à dire sur alesi débattent
et fait remonter vos idées puis tout ça
et les marcheurs bon nom voyez cru à
cette horizontalité à cette démocratie
interne
à ce foyer tas de mots anglais en plus
avec ça que j'ai oublié mais bon et ici
on crut est finalement l arrivée bas le
pouvoir c'est bernard mourad qui le
négocier directement avec les dirigeants
d'entreprises dans les séances se
distinguer d'un feu de françois fillon
quoi donc voilà comment s'est construit
programme d'où une énorme déception
quand on parle de déception avec les
marcheurs moi j'ai rencontré un certain
nombre de marchés
si on lâchait il y en a beaucoup le
mouvement pourquoi parce que on leur a
fait croire à la démocratie on leur a
fait croire à la présidentialité on leur
a fait croire que leur débat et puis
tout ça et servir à quelque chose
finalement
c'est venu d'en haut classique mais moi
j'ai participé à autre chose c'est les
états généraux de l'alimentation ou
voilà à la fois pour que les
agriculteurs vivent mieux pour qu'on se
nourrissent mieux il avait été décidé de
faire ces états généraux tels autant la
révolution française mais concernant
l'alimentation bon ça veut dire qu'il ya
eu des dizaines de milliers d'heures de
consacrer à des débats à paris en
province avec la grande distribution les
syndicats agricoles les associations les
industriels les syndicats des
industriels les toutes les
interprofessions possible et à la fin ça
a accouché d'une cacahuète
donc je crains que la conclusion du
grand débat ça soit une cacahuète
là aussi voir une cacahuète dont on a
déjà décidé ce qu'elle serait quoi non
on verra mais peut-être qu'il aura
l'habileté de prolonger sa part les
commissions des réflexions des machart
pour ckoi tu sais j'ai lu la guerre des
preuves de eric
car tu as lu ce bouquin au pardon je
recommande donc c'est un bouquin qui
vient de paraître
c'est à l'auteur que j'aime beaucoup tu
sais par ailleurs c'est quand tu es
députés quand tu es tu vois dans cette
énergie dans ce truc là
comment tu fais pour pas devenir con
c'est un défi c'est un défi que de
réussir à garder du temps pour lire
écrire pensée respirer c'est à dire pour
moi a mené notre parole dans la vie
publique tu vois et donc dans la guerre
des preuves de guillard il raconte
comment au xviie siècle
finalement les mouvements protestants
qui décrochait du catholicisme était
aussi les mouvements sociaux étaient une
guerre des ports
tu vois et il ya eu un mouvement très
puissant en angleterre et un moment le
roi et l'église anglicane ont réussi à
l'interrompt comment en dix ans
maintenant on va négocier et ils ont
fait en lisez les négociations et la
file ils ont réussi à couper la tête de
tous les leaders et puis tout ça mais il
est évident que quand tu as un mouvement
comme les gilet jaune qui a de l'ampleur
et puis tout ça il faut dire non
négociation débat c'est une manière de
geler ça fait partie de la bataille quoi
donc il faut voir si au terme de ce
grand débat qui se termine donc le 14
mars on parvient à remettre du jura
machine moi je fais mon possible pour
nous je fais mon possible pour avec la
parole fait mon possible pour avec un
livre qui fournit des arguments je fais
mon possible pour avec un film où on
viendra je l'espère rire pleurer lui est
espéré quoi parle du train de vie des
élus ça fait partie des choses dont on
parle beaucoup au sein du mouvement des
gilets jaunes mais aussi dans les
commentaires aujourd'hui certains disent
aujourd'hui voilà c'est au bas de cette
déconnexion du présent arrêt public
vis-à-vis du
du peuple est ce qu'aujourd'hui que
quand on est député ministres
secrétaires d'état ou un sénateur ou
autre voilà on a des salaires importants
où on a peut avoir tendance à se
déconnecter de ce qu'est la vie de
beaucoup de français
finalement est-ce qu'il ya pas des
choses à changer il ya certains qui
pensent qu'il faudrait baisser leur
salaire à mettre un salaire qui serait
un salaire moyen de celui des français
oui ces deux questions du d'un bug alors
à rentrer là des collections et aussi
qu'est ce qu'on peu férus éviter ça ou
est ce qu'il faut faire même quelque
chose tu sais que je veux payent au smic
mais voilà c'est comme ça c'est réglé
bon donc
mais je crois alors ils l'argument que
jean sala députés soient ses 5000 5750
700 euros et et vous avez pré décision
de vous mettre au smic voilà loin mais
je crois que enfin je crois que ce n'est
pas le coeur du problème mais je
généralise ce que j'entends plutôt sur
le rond point c'est qu'il faut baisser
les salaires parce que ça à faire
économiser de l'argent
ah oui ça se boucle je dois dire que je
pense que je suis pas d'accord mais
c'est pas grave je veux dire la
démocratie elle a appris par exemple je
suis pas d'accord avec la diminution du
nombre de députés je sais que ça
un truc j'en discute sur les
ronds-points on prend un point mais moi
je crois que on a besoin le député comme
pour moi un service public de proximité
et que je vous comme on a une gare comme
on a une poste comme on a une école eh
bien il est bon d'avoir un député qu'on
puisse interpeller pas trop loin de chez
soi et que je veux pas un d'éloignement
alors le problème c'est que comme pour
les gars comme pour la poste comme pour
les hôpitaux
quand on veut les privatiser les le
train fonctionne tellement mal par
exemple moi tu vas encore du retard ce
matin sur la ligne amiens paris que
quand il ya la décision privatisation
audiard se sont vu comment c'est le
merdier
on verra bien ce que ça donnera ça peut
pas être pire c'est un peu pareil pour
les élus vu comment de toute façon on a
l'impression qu'ils servent à rien et
c'est pas faux parce que l'assemblée
elle sert pas à grand chose je les dis
eh bien on se dit bon bah autant
supprimer du personnel là dedans que tu
voies dont moi je crois que la question
démocratique centrale c'est comment on
rend 1
le à l'assemblée nationale comment on
fait pour koné dans ce pays ça soit pas
un président qui avec ses quatre
reprises c'est ce désir c'était la
définition du despotisme de montesquieu
décide du sort de la nation voilà c'est
ça la question est pour moi la le la
grande question institutionnelle qu'on
devrait avoir c'est comment on redonne
du poids à l'assemblée comme on redonne
du poids aux citoyens et comment on fait
que tous les pouvoirs ne soit pas
aujourd'hui concentrée entre les mains
d'un seul homme
et c'est pas en diminuant le nombre de
députés ou en diminuant leurs revenus
qu'on répond à cette question là on peut
le faire lui diminué revenus moi je m'en
fous mais ça répond pas à cette question
là et je crois que pareil moi tu vois
par exemple j'aurais été favorable à ce
qu' on puisse former un binôme avec ma
suppléante est allé une semaine sur deux
à l'assemblée nationale pourquoi pas ce
que ça donnerait du temps l'autre
semaine pour respirer
bon je regarde alterné aussi ça
donnerait du temps pour respirer pour
continuer à rencontrer les gens près de
chez soi
tandis que là je vois comment on est
pris en étau et comment il va y avoir
amené un accord entre le président de la
république et le peuple pour nous
prendre en étau et demandé à ce qu'on
soit présent dans l'hémicycle et dans
une forme de présence yayisme ou lui il
nous veut là bas du lundi au vendredi
voire le samedi et dimanche à voter des
lois en série kung pour un certain
nombre moi je ne comprends pas parce
qu'elles sont pas passés par la
commission par exemple bon et donc du
coup nous enfermer et nous enfermer dans
un rôle de contrôle d'évaluation et de
contrôle évaluation succès quoi moi j'ai
pas j'ai pas je suis pas là pour pour
être chez andersen consulting quoi je
suis pas de l'audit
moi je veux parler de la démocratie
je veux venir apporter des idées qu'à
l'école on veut qu'elle justice on veut
quelle démocratie on veut et tout ça
c'est pas avec du contrôle et de
l'évaluation
donc je vois comment on veut une
technocrate ise tu vois et on est déjà
largement technocrates c'est pour ça que
ça peut marcher quoi mais c'est comment
on remet de l'air dans tout ça voilà
donc
évidemment la la réforme
institutionnelle et macro on va dire que
c'est une demande populaire et mâcha
mais c'est pas se demander comment casse
le cordon entre l'assemblée l'elysée
sait même pas comment rallonge à taille
de l'asse encore un raccourcissement la
taille de la laisse donc moi je ne suis
pas du tout d'accord avec cette
orientation là c'est le loup et le chien
puisse louer veut pas de collier je pas
un collier qui m'attache à l'elysée quoi
en plus en question pour thalys fait
parce que vous ses attendus et notamment
des questions les commentaires qui veut
que le fait qu'il y avait un député mois
décembre qui avait entrepris via un
article de permettre la destitution du
président et noël macouin qui dit bah
vous voilà vous êtes totalement opposés
le matin quand on vous ment et sa
démission pourquoi vous n'avez pas
entamer cette procédure même si on sait
que c'est pas avec une 2 vers sa bouche
mais pas simplement pour couver
peut-être va être chaud à cette question
que je me pose en toute honnêteté mais
maintenant tu sais j'ai déjà tellement
sentiment d'être isolés est
régulièrement même si je suis bien j'en
ai parlé au sam en groupage évoqué la
question lui mais ce qui pourrait pas y
aller tu vois allons-y franchement quoi
donc je je je me suis posé la question
je peux pas dire que je me la pose pas
encore maintenant j'ai déjà paraît déjà
comme étant tellement un marginal en
système
c'est fatiguant quoi maintenant des
tanks en plus marginalisés bah oui mais
tu vas prendre des décisions tout seul
tu il faut que j'arrive à entraîner un
certain nombre de deux volontés avec moi
même si de toute façon c'est maintenant
le groupe parlementaire de la france
obligée pas que je peux pas dire que
j'ai mis les couverts régulièrement je
l'évoqué comme ça et puis bon ça c'est
tellement un acte de rupture que bon je
pense qu' il faudrait en parler mais bon
voilà peut-être sais que je peux en font
avoir
oui mais dans la déjà discuté mais les
médecins comme ça c'est pas ça pas été
au coeur ça pas non plus été au coeur
d'une discussion
mais oui c'est une question que je me
pose maintenant c'est c'est tellement un
art un acte de pure symbolique fois la
convergence cole est il pour vous du
groupe we have oulémas raffin a minima
il faudrait mois je souhaiterais que il
ya une union des insoumis et les
communistes d'un certain nombre de
députés qui disent bon bah voilà
la mesure est dépassée quoi moi tu vas
par exemple un truc que je sais pas si
il ya eu aujourd'hui mon collègue l'oin
prud'hommes qui s'est pris des coups de
matraque
oui et justement c'est un échange
intéressant parce que il ya eu six ans
est ce qui s'est passé du côté de
bordeaux où justement les prud'hommes a
interpellé le lait mise à la terre
christophe castaner il ya des réponses
très voilà dix ans il n'y avait rien à
faire là en prenant même certains faits
lui fait quitter son bouclier etc
voilà près virulentes de la part d'un
fan absolu on a des députés qui se
prendre des coups de matraque fera
figure le préfet qui lie la police a
fait son travail et le ministre
l'intérieur qui dit c'est qu'il couvre
le préfet en disant c'est normal qu'un
député se prennent des coups de matraque
il avait qu'à pas être là bon même s'il
faisait rien mais tu vois moi ce qui me
choque je trouve que là ça touche à
représentants mais tu vois on a eu une
semaine après semaine des estropiés dr
bernier des mutilés tu vois les photos
les gars peut être qu'ils sont pas ils
n'avaient pas à être là mais bon sang
c'est humain tu es président la
république tu es premier ministre et
ministre de l'intérieur
à un moment tu dis ça on est désolé tu
dis aux familles ça va pas tu dis aux
victimes ça va pas tu dis tu demandes ce
que tu vas faire pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas le samedi d'après je vois
ce que je veux dire tu as un mot de
compassion et moi depuis tout le temps
qu'il ya eu tout ça et là on en est à
des des dizaines et des dizaines de gens
dont la vie sera plus la même après
parce qu'ils ont participé à des
manifestations qui ont qui avait aucun
acte de violence qui traînait par là tu
vois il ya quand même eu des morts aussi
à marseille
une vieille dame qui meurt et tu entends
pas des mots d'excusés des mots de
compassion
c'est comme si en fait je vais te dire
le coeur
j'ai entendu ce mot c'est le néo
darwinisme
on est dans un néo darwinisme ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que la classe
dirigeante
rattaché à l'oligarchie considère qu'au
fond une appartenons plus à la même
espèce et que donc les hommes en jaune
et les gens qui ne sont rien on peut
venir les humiliés par des propos mais
aussi les estropiés sans que ça ait sans
que cela soit nos semblables
tu vois et moi je dis simplement nous
sommes nous sommes semblables bordel tu
vois tu sais c'est vrai que je ne peux
pas ne pas relier ça au fait par exemple
au comportement à l'égard du
réchauffement climatique quand une amie
revient la city me raconte que les
traders ils sont en train d'investir en
norvège parce que c'est là bas qu'ils
pensent qu'ils vont pouvoir échapper au
réchauffement ou alors que dans la
silicon valley et avec des gens auxquels
emmanuel macron est très attaché tu vois
il faudrait s'interroger je le fais pas
tu vas s'est passé philosophique de ce
point de vue là mais sur la relation de
d'emmanuel macron aux nouvelles
technologies à tout ce qui est start up
à ce qui pourrait être aussi l'homme
augmenté
et donc quand tu vois que la silicon
valley prépare sa migration en masse en
nouvelle-zélande pour échapper au
réchauffement ben voilà on a là une
hyper classe qui pensent qu'elle va
échapper au sort commun quoi et moi mon
oeuvre
c'est de tenter de dire mais bordel on
est sur le même bateau il faut qu'on
fasse société il faut que cette hyper
classe qui est sur son moulin avec le
président jupiter il faut qu'on la
ramène sur terre quoi il faut qu'on la
ramène parmi ces violences policiers on
vous pourriez quelques instants chez
nous
par la fin même plus d'émotions vous
pleurait mais mon volant samedi
certaines images finalement ce maintien
de l'ordre aujourd'hui contestée parce
qu'il ya des milliers de blessés du côté
des gilets jaunes ya aussi beaucoup du
côté des forces de l'ordre est ce qu'on
aurait pu éviter ça et si oui comment
écoute moi je suis pas spécial du
maintien de l'ordre mais je sais que le
il ya eu un changement de doctrine dans
le maintien de l'ordre en france sous
emmanuel macron tu vas le fait qu'on
retourne à des choses beaucoup plus
mobile compte poursuivre les gens qu'on
tire de loin et tout ça il ya eu un
changement de doctrine qui fait que
c'est plus la même chose je suis pas
spécialiste de ça mais je pense que je
pense que c'était parfaitement évitable
en tout cas on peut pas tirer sur des
gens qui sont en train de rien faire tu
vas sinon participé à une manifestation
est derrière ne pas se demander mais ou
même ton notre démocratie quoi vous
mettre une tombe notre pays
christophe caterino démissionner pour
vous aujourd'hui oui oui mais si tu veux
moi je souhaite aussi la démission du
président de la république n'ont qu'eux
mais voilà je souhaite la démission du
poids jean république je veux peut-être
qu'on va faire terminer oui ces
questions à finir voilà moi je crois que
la légitimité du président à la public
entamée parce que je mets à nu dans mon
livre c'est à dire une espèce
d'élections truquées avec ses
accointances permanente avec les grands
patrons de presse qui lui réserve une
couverture qui est pas du tout
équivalente à celle des autres candidats
et à partir de ce moment là mon acte
pour moi une une élection qui est quand
même trafic et donc il faut que les gens
aient puissent partir les candidats
puissent partir à égalité dans cette
course là donc
voilà et moi de toute façon je souhaite
qu'ils aient une démission pour qu'on
arrive un autre alors soit une autre
république mais que de toute façon il ya
un rééquilibrage des pouvoirs et que tu
vois tu parles de 2022
ça veut dire je vois comment les
journalistes et les journalistes
politiques sont il ya une névrose les
névroses du personnel politique et
névroses du journaliste politique et
névroses de tout ce qui touche à la
politique en france qui est l'élection
présidentielle quoi c'est grave de se
dire que la démocratie c'est une fois
tous les cinq ans et que la vie
politique la vie démocratique
elle va tourner autour d'un seul homme
pendant cinq ans et tu vois moi appel je
suis élu député
on est en juin 2017
et dès les jours qui suivent presque ou
les semaines qui suivent on m'interroge
sur 2022
on vient à peine de passer 2017
j'aimerais commentaires ils étaient
nombreux aussi et c'est de là devient
cette question moi j'étais tellement
j'avais même pas préparer celle ci est
bien des gens qui nous regardent qui
étaient très nombreux bas voilà avoir
cette ambition plus loin pour vous ce
que vous avez fait part de l'ambition
aussi perso oui je pense que ceci laisse
là dessus les gens non mais j'ai une
ambition pour ce printemps c'est déjà de
participer à je l'espère un mouvement
social et de tu vois je le dis mais moi
les gens qui étaient sur les murs de ma
chambre c'était pas des dirigeants
politiques et les grands mouvements que
j'apprécie c'est des mouvements de
d'effervescence populaire
les remparts ont déferlé sens populaire
il ya ce qui se passe actuellement en
algérie on le voit depuis maintenant
près de deux semaines le peuple algérien
qui se soulèvent contre le fait qu'un
président bouteflika président en place
depuis vingt ans se présente pour un
cinquième mandat vous ça vous inspire
quoi
ben ça m'inspire beaucoup de sympathie
évidente toi
bon il ya un effet peut-être aussi lié à
la rente pétrolière comme on le voit
dans d'autres pays
qui sait font donc peut-être qu'il y ait
des soubassements économique une révolte
populaire
mais comment ne pas comprendre que les
gens souhaitent d'autres dirigeants pour
leur pays que quelqu'un qui voit même
plus elle apparaître à la télévision qui
est enfin voilà avant je ne dis pas
qu'il faut tout le temps un dirigeant de
41 ans et que ça résout tout puisque je
vis d'écrire un livre là-dessus mais
enfin une société qui est jeune comme
l'algérie je comprends parfaitement que
les gens ils aspirent à autre chose quoi
pour conclure ce live peut-être une
question la france de françois ruffin
commencerait tél
vous avez fait beaucoup de constats sur
la politique menée par le gouvernement
actuellement mais comment faire pour
aujourd'hui toutes ces situations vous
avez évoqué dans votre livre avec
beaucoup de passion beaucoup de force
ces personnes en difficulté comment
faire en sorte pour qu'elle ait un
avenir meilleur que celui qui ne veut
pas tuer ce n'est pas possible de
raisonner une question comme celle là en
trente secondes à la fin d'un jeu assez
évident maintenant je vais redire ce que
j'ai dit à un moment dans le truc de
toute façon je sais pas en termes de moi
j'ai pas de société idéale tu vois je
sais que on n'arrivera pas à la société
idéale que pour moi elle n'existe pas
que il ya un chemin mais il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas un but ultime
il n'y a pas de fans l'histoire donc
l'histoire est en permanence à
recommencer en revanche il faut que les
gens qui arrivent au pouvoir
il est une obsession c'est le bonheur de
cindy c'est le bonheur de marie c'est le
bonheur de zoubir et c'est pas le
bonheur ou les dividendes de xavier niel
vincent bolloré arnaud lagardère et
patrie dry tu vas je ne sais pas que je
leur souhaite du malheur à ses hommes
mais l'obsession de gens qui sont élus
par le peuple
ça doit être le bonheur du peuple c'est
tout ah merci beaucoup françois ruffin
alors je vais pas vous donner dans les
mains parce qu'on ne fait aucun doute
mais j'ai quand même le montre à l'image
ce livre j'aime être comme ça pour
montrer à ceux qui le regardent
françois ruffin ce pays que tu ne
connais pas bienvenus en france monsieur
mâcon c'est ce livre qu'on a évoqué que
moi qui
dans toutes les librairies front depuis
quelques jours maintenant oued baht
maintenant deux semaines maintenant
voilà ben on vous remercie en tout cas
beaucoup
françois ruffin d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'était ma première interview
dans la médiation depuis début d'année
2010 neuf ans après donc trois mois vous
étiez consacré à écrire ce livre est
aussi ce film je veux du soleil qui est
en lien justement que ce mouvement des
légions tout à fait parce que je produis
un diptyque qui est quelque part un film
d'amour et un livre de combat même s'il
ya aussi de l'amour pour les gens dont
le livre mais enfin c'est un livre de
combat en faveur de la démocratie et
contre l'oligarchie qu elle va merci
beaucoup françois ruffin pour cette
interview sans langue de bois que vous
pouvez tous voir ou revoir pour ceux qui
nous suivent sur cela qu'ils viennent
d'arriver maintenant rien n'est perdu
dans quelques instants le live se
termine et vous pourrez retrouver en
intégralité
merci à tous ceux qui l'ont suivi et
puis merci encore à vous françois
macerola xiao